what I want to do in this video is talk
about the processes that make all life
as we know it life as we know it and at
its essence we can call this metabolism
tabble ism and this is the taking energy
in different forms breaking it down into
its more fundamental components and then
building it up in ways that we would
find useful useful for energy useful for
structure so that we can actually live
our lives we can grow we can reproduce
we can respond to our surroundings so as
I just said metabolism and we're going
to go into a bunch of examples of this
metabolism at its heart is really two
different processes there's the breaking
down of substances for energy or for
structure to get back to the building
blocks and we call that catabolism
catabolism so this is the breaking down
of things and then once we've broken
down things we're ready to rebuild them
in ways that we would find useful and we
call this a Nabal ism and Nabal ism or
anabolism and a Nabal ism just like that
and one way to think about it is imagine
that someone had built something with
Legos and you want to build something
with Legos well you could go to those
Legos and you'd want to break it down
but not break it down too much you
wouldn't melt the plastic you would
break it down into the individual LEGO
pieces and then you would build it back
up into whatever shape that you actually
cared about and you might not actually
have to even build it break it down all
the way to the basic LEGO pieces there
might be structures in that first Lego
castle that was constructed that you
might find useful so let's just think
about how all of this gets started and
what's excited is what's exciting is
that all of this got started or get
started from stars from fusion reactions
and stars and this right over here is a
picture of a star and a star that we are
very familiar with this is the Sun but
you may or may not realize that the Sun
is only one of probably several stars
that have been involved in life as we
know it the Sun is our most direct
source of energy for most of life as we
know there's
some bacteria and things that are able
to live off of vents at the bottom of
the ocean because of the heat created
but the Sun is our primary source of
energy but when I say that other stars
might have been involved including dead
stars that existed billions of years ago
it's because the heavier elements that
we're composed of or that are around us
in are in the environment the carbon the
oxygen we could just keep going pretty
much everything other than hydrogen it
was constructed in fusion reactions from
hydrogen inside of stars so we really
may are made up of the remnants of stars
and so here we are we're on earth earth
was all this condensed matter from
four-and-a-half billion years ago
probably some nearby supernovae got all
of this dust that was constructed in a
previous star to coalesce in that way
and you have radiation you have energy
from the Sun and once again that energy
is coming from fusion reactions and it's
what's fusing lighter elements into
heavier elements so the Sun is also
constructing more heavy elements but
that energy that energy makes its way to
the earth and you have organisms like
plants that are able to use that energy
to construct the the material the the
the food we could say that is eventually
going to get around to us and so this
process you may or may not be familiar
with it this is photosynthesis and we're
going to go into a lot more detail since
this is and as the word implies photo
its photosynthesis it's making things
out of light and one thing I like to ask
people when they are first exposed to
photosynthesis that's like okay we could
see this grass growing or we could see
this wheat growing and we could see a
tree growing but where is that material
coming from and the most common answer
so somehow it's coming from the ground
and there are some new trick nutrients
that are coming from the ground but it's
really all about fixing carbon and
you're going to hear about this a lot
especially as we talk about the carbon
cycle but you have carbon dioxide
primarily in the air so you have carbon
you have I'll just write it this way so
you have carbon dioxide in the air and
what photosynthesis allows these plants
to do is take the carbon in that carbon
dioxide
and form bonds with it turn it from its
gas form into solid forms into into
glucose molecules and then use that
glucose to build up cellulose and to
build out other forms of starch and
whatever else it might be so it's taking
these molecules in the air I'll just
draw them as these little is taking
these molecules that are in the air and
it's using the energy of the Sun to fix
them to actually to actually form bonds
between the carbons and with other
things as we said we're mostly carbon
and hydrogen we have some oxygen in
there but we're able to form these
structures now from there other living
organisms and this is a huge
oversimplification it can involve
bacteria it can involve all sorts of
things and just to just to reminder even
on that photosynthesis it isn't just
light and it isn't just the carbon
dioxide it also involves the water and
we talked about that so you also have
water involved you also have the water
involved so you know the carbon dioxide
so co2 light from the Sun and water
you're able these things are able to
grow and nutrients from the earth and
then from that you're able to construct
things like well you can directly go to
these plants that are taking energy from
the Sun and and and construct things
like bread or you have other animals
that will eat things like the grass and
then use their and then break them down
in their own way and they'll be assisted
by bacteria and then rebuild themselves
up into a cow into milk and so what this
cow is doing its metabolizing this grass
it's able to break it down it's able to
catabolized the the the various
molecules in the grass and break them
down into building blocks that can then
use to build up the cow to build up milk
and whatever else and you might be
saying what are these types of molecules
that we keep breaking down and then
building back up well you have
carbohydrates carbohydrates and you're
going to see most of the molecules that
I'm just I'm about to talk about frankly
all of them on the back of nutritional
package because it tells you what's
inside of it what is your body going to
metabolize when it eats that whatever
or whatever your on the packet whatever
is inside of the package so
carbohydrates these are either simple
sugars like glucose or fructose or it
could be it could be polymers of the
sugars polysaccharides it could be a
starches made up of many many elements
of the or many many multiples of these
simple sugars we could be talking about
lipids lipids so fatty acids we could be
talking about cholesterol these are
essential structures and they're also
essential for all various metabolic
pathways inside of all of life or it
could be proteins it could be proteins
made up of amino acids sometimes people
say the reason why you want the proteins
is because it's made up of these amino
acids so you could break down these
proteins and get the amino acids and
then build it up into new proteins
proteins and amino acids and all of
these things they are found in things
like in the foods in the foods we eat
which we will then consume we will then
metabolize we will first catabolized
them and break them down and then we
will use those building blocks to build
it back up and at the end of the day
these are these provide the structures
that make our bodies what they are they
allow us to interact with our
environment and they provide energy and
that energy at the end of the day with
the true molecular currency for that
energy is a molecule called ATP that's a
molecule of ATP right over there
adenosine triphosphate and the key for
ATP why it is the molecular currency for
energy are the three phosphate groups so
it has these three phosphate groups and
we have a whole we have a whole video on
it or a whole series of videos on it
really but the the main key is that
there's a lot of energy especially
between the I guess on the last
phosphate group and this energy in that
bond as the phosphate group breaks off
it can release it to provide all sorts
of life mechanisms including being able
to metabolize things so ATP right over
here this is the currency of energy in
life as we know it and it's actually an
interesting molecule because it's
essentially it's a piece of if you just
were to take if you were to just
this section of it right over here it
really is it looks like a piece of RNA
it looks like you're taking a you have
the ribose you have the adenine you have
a phosphate group and it can actually be
used to construct things like RNA and
even DNA beyond just being the molecular
currency of energy so it's fun to see
how these pieces all fit together how
they can be broken up and you see these
patterns over and over again in
biological systems and these biological
systems are really just made up of
breaking down and building back up
carbohydrates lipids including fatty
acids cholesterol other things and
proteins / amino acids so this whole
thing you know look around you look at
your day look at the things you're
consuming and you'll see this pattern
over and over and over again and it's
all a little mind-blowing because at the
end of the day the energy is coming from
the fusion reaction in stars and all of
the heavy elements around you or even
the not so heavy elements all of the
carbon the oxygen all of the really
non-hydrogen elements they've even been
made inside of fusion reactions in in
print in stars that might have existed
billions and billions and billions of
years ago so hopefully that makes you
feel a little bit more connected to the
universe